hi everybody uh thanks for participating
in the meet pete hashtag i'm gonna
answer some of the uh twitter ones some
of the twitter ones
miss ari shane says what's going to be
your unique thing to set you apart from
the rest beyond your awesome golden
boyishness boyishness buenas of course
uh well you know i think there's going
to be a couple things that set the show
apart but mostly uh it's going to be
more me
so it's going to be like conan but the
monologue will be more like my stand up
and the interview will be more like my
podcast and the bits will be more like
my overall sensibility which is as you
touched upon a golden retriever if it
stood up
this one's from uh at blurg pawamp
blurg
p womp
they want to know what's your rap name
is petey pablo taken petey pablo
p p wheatgrass i think would be a good
one ghost face killer ghost just ghost
face
rap buddy
uh s
death the skin slicer
a lot of things rhyme with slicer
dicer
j smitty 2013 he changes it every year
what advice would you give to an
aspiring comedian
some of the best comedy advice i ever
got in my life was from bill burr he
said keep your head down don't be a dick
and you'll get in and that's true a lot
of comedians go around
wanting to be on tv right away wanting a
deal right away
doing it for money doing it for fame the
only thing that i know that works is
doing it for the sake of the comedy
doing it because you're creating the art
that you would like to see in the world
pam's horror
says what's the format talk show sketch
investigative reporting
there is going to be kind of a current
affair hard copy vibe to the whole
production i think that's going to be a
thing we're going to have a lot more
sketch than a typical late night show
kind of like the stuff we've done with
batman that sort of feels some of the
doctor sketches that sort of feel you
can get a taste of that at petehomes.com
the monologue is going to be more in
line with my stand up more
conversational a little less set up
punchline so i think that will be
different and then i think the interview
portion is going to be a lot weirder
it's going to be a lot of my friends a
lot of my comedian friends and i think a
lot of the time we'll be slanting in a
way that is unexpected and maybe
one hard-hitting story about monsanto's
genetically modified plants
because
what they're doing is up and they
need to be stopped
you can't own the earth monsanto
you